[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
we've talked about name Imaging likeness
and where it's going basically what you
have right now in college football is
you have speed limits but nobody's
enforcing there's no police like hey you
shouldn't be going that that fast or
you're not allowed to do there's nobody
enforcing it but there's speed limit
signs but nobody is acknowledging or a
stop sign and then I saw this story
about uh Jaden rashada Florida bound
quarterback and uh Alan Taylor the
athletic wrote an article about this you
know he's very popular on social media
this quarterback four-star five-star
quarterback and he was supposed to the
gator Collective they were going to give
him a name image and likeness contract
valued at more than 13 million dollars
now the collective is different than the
school or the athletic department it's
like a booster group there then he
already flipped he was committed to
Miami he was supposed to be getting a 9
million dollar nil deal then he went to
Florida now he's in Florida now he wants
to leave Florida because he's not
getting his money let's bring in Alan
Taylor's done a great job covering this
how did I do in summing that up there
Alan
spot on man thank you uh 1800 fewer
words than it took me
okay how did the collective at Florida
get him to flip from Miami to Florida
yeah he flipped on November 10th and
then we find out subsequently that on
November 7th are thereabouts uh there
was a 13 million dollar offer extended
by the collective which a little more
background on the collective is they're
a crowdsourcing sort of just getting
started 18 months in deal that that
doesn't have 13 million dollars that's
why a second Collective from Florida
began last year of Mega donors to sort
of handle the big buys if you will uh
whereas this Collective is probably
probably has enough money to cover the
Olympic sports
um so that 13 million dollar pledge
clearly was based on a promise from
someone else at another Collective or
another donor uh that hasn't been
confirmed it although everybody has a
pretty good guess at which donut donor
it is uh and then of course by December
7th which is two weeks before the early
signing period
a notice to terminate that contract was
sent out I'm told that was there was a
window to terminate the contract but as
you can imagine on the rashada side
having flipped the commitment
um that could be problematic he still
signed with Florida on December 21st it
took a couple hours extra to get that
signing in the the press conference with
Napier was scheduled for 4 P.M it didn't
start till after five because there were
waiting on some of that behind the
scenes stuff to happen and then even on
uh January 3rd I talked to rashada in
Orlando at an Under Armor game the kid
was really excited about Florida had the
formations already uh in this possession
and was studying them and then when it
comes time to enroll last week uh
whatever renegotiations were going on
didn't come to fruition and now he's
asked for a scholarship release yeah I
talked to a source yesterday when I told
him we were going to be talking about
this and he said Florida is known in the
college recruiting uh Community as over
promising and he said not surprised
about this that they over promised and
then you get on campus now where you're
going to go and maybe you're going to
get a different deal than what you
thought but is this legal that that you
know if you're recruiting with nil
before he gets there he knows that he's
supposed to be making 13 million dollars
it's totally against NCAA guidelines but
still and yet every school I'm told is
doing it to some degree and they're you
know they're parsing it where maybe you
don't sign the contract until you're on
campus but it's promised uh Billy Napier
both on the record and off has been
adamant that Florida doesn't want to
entice recruits he wants to take care of
the the guys who are on his roster and
already in the building which is really
the genuine Spirit of nil but at the
same time
you know that this couple classes before
they they try to regulate this somehow
it's it's a high dollar value these
recruits have and um you know one of the
sources told me for that story you
referenced that there's no way Billy
Napier was going to make this kid the
second highest paid person in the
building
um and and truly this this Florida
situation is not of the the making of
the athletic department but it's
entirely Theirs to clean up because you
have to you have to get all these
different entities on the same page
because the headline says Napier and
Florida lost a quarterback not the gate
who collected why was the offer pulled
I think the the behind the scene
promises for that money uh didn't pan
out and weren't uh presented in writing
and so they had to scramble before
Signing Day and whatever happened
between December 7th and December 21st
was enough to
uh get Rashad to sign which as you know
is a binding National letter of intent
uh so uh but now he's asked for his
release and I fully expect Florida is
just going to move on unless there's
some really strong threat of litigation
that might
present them from just releasing him
right off the bat you know I think some
of the parties behind the scenes want to
be cleared of all uh responsibility on
this is he worth it
no no he's not and uh but then again the
market is what the market is right there
were houses sold all across this country
that weren't worth uh the bottom line
the last few years
um
I talked to sources who had trouble
believing that Miami was even offering
him 9 million when he saw when he
committed to Miami uh last summer uh so
it's hard for me to digest these numbers
and I know fans say they're not real
they are ludicrous but in this case
it was offered uh but then you know
quite frankly when it came time to get
him in school
they they don't think he's a 13 million
dollar quarterback which would be a four
or five year term by the way not not
annually
um no one does our Arch Manning isn't
getting that kind of deal Nico at
Tennessee
is apparently getting 8 million over
four years and that's probably the the
richest deal that's been uh signed yet
can the NCAA investigate do they even
have an investigative department for
college football
I was told by a source that no one is
worried about the NCAA because they're
Toothless and that no one is really even
worried about the Florida state law
which was one of the the first states to
to pass one uh that says you know an
athlete can't receive payment
until he's on campus and enrolled well
obviously uh this will be a violation of
that but again A source told me that
that no one's enforcing that Florida law
either now in California
high school kids can can be paid but
this is still a contract issued
obviously by a Florida entity so
apparently that law would uh would be
the one that takes precedent we're
talking Alan Taylor the Florida beat
rider for the athletic covering this
name image and likeness story you cover
the SEC
uh a m felt like they were at the
Forefront of doing this but Jimbo Fisher
said they don't do this uh Nick Saban
when he prior to the season was talking
to his boosters saying hey we got to
step up so everybody's kind of doing
that right in front of everybody
correct yeah yeah that's the thing uh
you know the argument for name image and
like you saw these years were that the
school's making money and athletes on
campus aren't getting any of it well the
minute that this became a deal and it
was sort of opened up
you knew that all that below the table
money that had uh perpetuated in
recruiting all these years
most of it was going to be moved above
the table and now athletes are going to
pay taxes on it they're going to be
contracts the holdup was that can't be
promised or signed before they get on
campus and by the time you get them on
campus well obviously uh those deals
have to be
solidified so uh I think it's just added
a little bit of transparency to the
nastiness of recruiting uh but in a
situation like this who knows this isn't
going to end up being a test case and
maybe even a how not to for collectives
across the country
best nil store you've heard without
naming names
well multiple kids and I say kids
they're going into college multiple all
Americans at the Under Armor game off
the Record said that they were receiving
almost nil cold calls on Signing Day
from schools they had not even visited
as though you know there was a a call
center set up somewhere where they were
just random dialing top 200 players and
saying hey if you're at all not thinking
about signing the school X School y will
give you you know several hundred
thousand and I will say there was a
Florida player who was not in the portal
last year who was approached by a school
with a written offer for several hundred
thousand dollars and Florida's nil staff
looked into it and the company making
the offer was 72 hours old
it had just been Incorporated
it's like the bride is walking down the
aisle and you're there at the wedding
and say hey hey before before you do it
I I'm your high school boyfriend here
you want to reconsider uh we had a
moment at the rehearsal dinner right
yeah
great job on this Alan uh I don't know
where we're headed but uh
you're right about whatever was under
the table it almost felt like under the
table was better than over the table and
and you know in some of these like
marijuana under the table as opposed to
everybody now can buy mayor I don't know
it's just kind of wild I think I just
compared marijuana to name image and
likeness
well name image in highness oh it will
happen eventually all right I'm there
for about one a week in a couple years
you're going to see these power five
schools break away and they'll be able
to fund the nil themselves versus having
third parties do it which is really
where this communication came from I
think I I agree with you uh Alan thank
you we appreciate your time my pleasure
Dan Alan Taylor